[Music]
perfect that's IM seen
same ship same crew new start new start
same moonshine ah they think your engine
thinks I can stop us from giving this an
old [ __ ] shovel I'd like to see them
try that's crazy talk oh let's go
captain Bernard I'd come down on the sky
yay I really damaged it'll [ __ ]
inspiration that we are the only ship
that is the same from last time I think
people will recognize you are the best
teamwork cuz we got the [ __ ] I just
realized this chat is gonna be watching
us in the spectator now [ __ ] Chad we got
impressive [ __ ] that guy
[ __ ] I say we leave that into I want
everyone to be like [ __ ]
Chad [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] you Chad oh this
is actually really good because both of
the enemy teams are short range ships
and we got long ranged um like
everything is about is long ring yes
perfect
so he and I talked to the beginning and
we decided that we were going to just
stop killer okay here we go here we go
oh dear yeah ready oh let's go scared
hold your lunches we've got to get this
good lunch food to lunch Sylvania mmm
before they HMS Yonatan catches us
hahahaha oh I believe it is if they can
beat the Americans
what no we don't have a country we're
Sky Pirates okay guys we're at loss for
enemy spotted saws yo you know you know
is that an enemy right there yeah yeah
right in front of us who the squid he's
talking swiggy don't don't done it all
I'm gonna try to hit him from afar ready
all right do what do we lose shot set
we're gonna go right at them
Jill oh I'm in it no no close oh yes
good you did I only know
nice nice oh my god hey cease moving too
fast down no no no already it's amazing
I love you get the shot oh oh sorry gun
reloading gun oops
[ __ ] oh no stuck stuck yes go too fast
I'm sorry
yeah yeah that's fine
come right in the damn face thank you
tosser you can escape sorrow nice
captain Maximilian Valentine you folk
captain of the sky Oh Oh brutal question
mark quick captain of this guy there we
go we're going we're going we're going
down on him we're going down boys okay
let me get ready captain
we're gonna effing real bad Oh reloading
captain I am I am effing in full reverse
I'm helping with the right side thing oh
it's too high on the number line cry
yeah yeah cry you got there we go yeah
yeah cry yeah yeah ancient mechanical
ship over now
the fools oh all right looks like our
ally is having some trouble with that
guy up come on okay we do it Joe fixin
ya there balloon is still really heard
right now good good good good good
let it be hurt letting hurt if you think
if you don't we're gonna over if it's
too close to the ground they are her
right now get the I got a mark against I
guess I'm getting um maybe drying it up
keep that gun up I will I will oh I'm
coming on them if you can sir uh-huh
almost almost are thank you for side now
hmm well no no we're turning rapidly
rapidly keep turning no what are you
this is necessary uh I've got work to do
mmm okay okay okay there's a smoke
screen we're going above it we're going
above it
as much as we can yes sir get in that
balloon we're gonna need the balloon
real all right fixing it Dodgers got it
I'm keeping the hot one you can firing
no no dude I'm Shane sir II I know we're
on them we're on them get ready to get
ready to fire again keep going
fight firing the depth firing damn it
yes
yeah the sharpest edge we got a ship
incoming on the left side lo and behold
balloon is fixed
turning we're talking we're trying to
ship and we're gonna just bomb them
they're slow they're slow and we can
stay out of range
mm-hmm firing autumns where's our ally
oh yeah luckily I'm down we got his
balloon down he's falling so I don't
know yeah I'm cherry sugar no gun
captain firing that's fine keep shooting
him keep shooting get it yes I'm working
yeah out of the sky get out of it oh
okay that was our ally that's Nick Abadi
from the Bronx captain we're getting
shot at Kevin that's fine we're going
down we're going down we have to Green
Bay we go with damn well not bad going
down no carefully going down
purposefully dissenting I believe you
kill the cat thanks Kevin
ran around fixing there's one of us
we're gonna go underneath them mixed in
can come up behind all right there in
the clothes I am so hard cabin
crewman we're gonna hit them unleash
grunt oh shoot captain channel your
anger locking the girls out of things
we're gonna go around the flak or
whatever this is the secure main gun
yeah there we go
plan ahead on all from behind rhetta's
cap on Becca great I think there's
another coffee news in a smug attack
okay Roy head on run pretty camp out
yourselves
kill kicks you captain Go Go Go killing
em yeah we go
this guy Kevin if I can't oh the other
ship is right behind us just so we know
okay I'll go we might want to try to get
them though we're doing a transect oh
we're gonna hit them again the big old
asses yeah they're ready to slow to
avoid already firing yeah
schedule we have the most ideal of guns
obviously what's that a one-shot datura
you're messing them bro I have no clue
set in to soldier on your haggis
evenings we got a squid coming up behind
us looks like our alloys pooping in to
help them I give it two blows sir yeah
it's above us love it - blows fine let's
find work okay I guess with us we can
reverse oops okay
firing okay we're reloading the gun
captain he's really on the ground I know
you is dead Hey someone stole our kill
on that one
I agree Joe come on fine we're gonna
we're gonna kill this one it's so nice
actually spite him I have a team that's
Vanessa that's real nice serious are you
ready yeah sorry Deb's dress yeah
just cuz you made it does he know you're
gonna fire my god this is amazing
yeah oh and this guy's going down shoot
his ass as long as they've got it oh
it's beautiful cry Oh God still
beautiful yes sir yes like oh man it's
mesmerizing it is so well made for six
weeks we're doing that right
hi guy I'm fixin yeah I got the bad end
got engine oh he's going down next oh ah
gets inside cos I got the gun firing
good good good good very good inherence
I'm firing so good
they stole our killer game oh man gosh
sorry
oh said oh we are pirates here be a
fitting end for their crew there's
another a bris bride right below us by
the way
fixing guns hmm we see no no we're gonna
get picked health right now oh yeah they
did
okay firing it can't even touch the
tutorial menu up right now simply
because I don't know oh okay
they spit in fire if they come around
the side I'll try to let him up a bit
again yes okay in this guy good work
good work nice shot we're gonna just
we're gonna chase him down I'm gonna try
out damn it
other binky
did you wipe that smoke that was awesome
yes this is I learned it from Johnny
Pokemon absolutely so apparently
apparently we're using these super new
guns they have I'm not sure what it's
called
vo it's called the island is a big gun I
thought we use let's call the McDonald
yes the big gun and it's like pretty big
but it's the new one and it's wonderful
although you have to leave the shot with
it and stuff and it only fires like
three shots yeah takes a skill gündüz
very skilled so we settled for I
broadcast until that's pretty act Iria
day they're shooting comedy
I needed mark to be a luncheon engineer
so we suffer cry here we go here we go
we're just working it him get him get
I'm on side gonna get him if you get me
that's extra sure
oh now I can't see it oh that's I can't
get that side gun to we're okay we're
sorry we can't we can't
I don't we got I'm not dead oh yeah I
gotta get it fighter for the doctor I
gotta put it up we're gonna go through
this smart fire right now George I got
hurt so good fix the balloon I got their
engines why can't
oh I wrote that we should all do a part
of it you know okay yeah
um crap I think I was words you see
another movie that we did not steal that
song from you think you'll think of Cher
give me about love lie about the late
those I remember that song so well it
used to be my favorite song back in
fourth grade I love that one we got his
voice is the same as my share voice mama
it's making shudder
that's more like Johnny Bravo than Elvis
but I guess a sound is him whoa whoa
also Johnny Bravo is Cher and Elvis if
they had a baby oh okay however it's me
Johnny Bravo Elvis Cher oh [ __ ] are we
talking there's gonna be some crazy fan
art after people watch this only from us
like just Johnny Bravo Elvis [ __ ] it's
Nathan making fun of the Europeans he's
like unless the Europeans pull together
we gotta set the mind games that's what
we got to do there we go
is this where we get salty no one else
is gonna get salty but us Oh God
so are we doing a two out of three or
what yeah we're doing it don't worry if
it looks like it if we win again what
they were saying is we're gonna do it
two out of three if we win again then
there will be a Redemption match where
we switch ships okay what yeah special
like nothing we're not gonna be on the
get the steel butterfly no we will
create a new ship we'll call it
we'll call it the steel mod ship will
call the friendship yes unstoppable
I always named my ships the grassy fries
the shitty
you know the Whammy KaBlam ii i never
was very optimist the Whammy feel like
that is asking for trouble so you're a
crewman aboard the Whammy KaBlam EI yeah
often you stay this much not actually
crash quite often that's that's pretty
much cuz I was captaining and I had no
skill in captaining you know what hmm
why am i win ya wanna this all this is
my Redemption match this races are oh my
god guys I realize this is really look
really I love everyone else who's a part
of this but really this is about us oh
it's absent obviously this entire
Redemption this is about our Redemption
we get entire things about a Redemption
yes this is going to a magician then I
feel like the developers arranged this
just to give us this moment yeah yeah
yeah this is sound thank you guys
there's my meetings good or bad but the
squid went double flamethrowers so it
murder every one of them
no murder that this gun that we have is
the best gun but it's in language so I
don't know if we'll oh I trust in you
captain you can maneuver us anywhere so
oranjee got you tah dah dah dah dah dah
dah dah dah dah okay I've got my shower
see see some boot we got this we got
this scoping out for swamp you choose
where's our teammate uh no do you find
any [ __ ] uh you know I haven't found
[ __ ] yet damn I have yet to find
[ __ ] I don't know you're gonna find
them aboard this is a tiny ship I was
dealing with your engine I'm looking for
[ __ ] out in the ether oh here let me
help you fix it
okay he's over there
I'm reversing for a minute just because
I want to make sure there's no that's a
bird that's a bird what that is a bird
what what occurred Thunder oh shoot the
bird shoot it
are we sure to burn society no it is up
it's a beautiful bird woman sorry I
missed the bird all right firmly now um
guys I didn't I heard Oh it exploded
shower oh right in front of us rainbow
us what autumn
he's calling : fire got him Oh [ __ ]
firing yeah okay wait for the captain
sir oh really hard to get the shot off
okay our our teammates are definitely
trying to lure us in so we're gonna go
the opposite direction behind us mm so
that's good that's fine is there like a
boy or something there just obey me
yeah press m to use the map mmm is man
all right we're gonna we're gonna we're
gonna circle around and get back to them
I feel like we need to stick together
whoa oh that oh who is that - oh right
what do that there's something to the
right I'm scared something there's a
bunch of evil things to the right boat
we're gonna avoid all of it for right
now and try and live free please codes
we can breathe in these clouds yes okay
sweet oh don't worry
goodness they're actually edible no
surprise
last time the clouds are the enemy you
gotta shoot at the clouds oh I know
No oh my gosh no I lied to the right
this is how it all went wrong but that's
we gotta keep our enemies close
close-ish I'm sorry okay you got burned
you fool
Burnie cry gone mad yes he's got the sky
sickness he's kiss get him off the guns
he got into those Lunchables they're
taking her to Las Alenia the Rodney ones
are really bad are you sure that's a lie
sir yes it is red it's the Red Team Red
Eagle day does that look like [ __ ] you
shot at in the before 20 minutes red is
dead
but blue is in the goo which means we
need to find them and make them do Yeah
right
crush I'm gonna goop them good standard
we're gonna go get a goop um all right
so now we're just hotter which is sad
yeah look in photos
oh it's like the honey on October oh I
got Sean Connery oh okay wait what we're
doing okay I mean their movie but short
brother behind us red homies are behind
us and then Oh mark you can be the guy
who's like I always wanted to see
Montana you're that guy okay 1 2 3
Montana doing the perfect I didn't know
you yeah Dodger you can be the engineer
who's like I don't want the deal with
this now cap upon get the ban I don't
want to deal with this right man it was
really good I don't know shop right now
yeah I don't see them where are they
everyone's getting slaughtered out
because there's they're actively trying
to hide from us yeah I've got my going I
just see Birds Kevin I'm seeing a lot of
birds well um that's better than nothing
you know lots of birds their heart rates
are happening the the birds might be
working for ya mess sputters uh he's
like a wizard is in the clouds they are
British they do have wizardry tricks mm
for the [ __ ] in the clouds is that
natural gem song I'm it's not
in the clouds
everybody caught up tomorrow it's fun
Kidz Bop close just look oh no I
wouldn't doubt it I honestly believe
they literally have finished
where did Joe has been no actually this
is tighter stay in the narrow parts
because they know that they're not gonna
agree Joe wants us to stay here I know I
know Joe I know it's Joe going to go get
up come about engines
why what are you doing come what fixing
fixing engine Oh cuz I did that whoops
all right buddy Shh son of a B I'm stuck
here again yeah there we go yeah I know
what you want to do if we stay out here
in the open they have to come to us and
if they want to win he'll come to us
that is very young yep cuz we already
have the victory from first round
somewhere they need to come I like it a
little bit of hay fever mmm I gotta take
it out on this guy hey hey stop that no
cry don't what are you doing
I'm scratching his back with bullets sir
good good work
crewman thank you sir oh here they come
where where where where well oh my god
they're over there look at them oh my
gosh don't be faces
I'll hang it on these faces balloon
because I just knocked it down x squared
that's going for my name No okay got
nervous they may come on it I got it
goblins all right we're gonna come in
right behind Joe and since he can take
damage and we can't we're gonna just F
these dudes up from behind him mmm okay
we're gonna come in with him Sir all
right
okay I want to effing right be my head D
yeah F&R we're gonna turn on reverse
later what see if you can fire on them
do a range Joe because I know they have
sniper rifles and they're gonna do the
exact same thing on a Joe ship mmm how's
Joseph sniper right he loves to shoot Oh
Oh the squid just shooting bits a fire
just like oh don't come near me I'm God
I sit I sit I'm gonna go a little closer
well you can oh these guys they did not
be strange to tax at all so I'm gonna
miss their cry you're closer okay oh
wait don't use an AI gunner what Wow
what this isn't right this is a cry oh
no no what did we lose him no I don't
know bike I'm trained to do best
probably for the best
okay they're dead oh who the hell are
you
malaria is this one of those [ __ ]
weekend
clomid you like we'd run so many cloud
[ __ ] and Max will use them oh alright
mark when you can are you shooting this
gun but I will do my best
[ __ ] I blow up lastly leave a shot front
I'm a bit you got it
don't you worry don't you worry Marty
dear do - I'm gonna did you hear this
[ __ ] out
yeah yeah did you get out we go down
shot good shot team how they blowed up
the shiz and working to come back dead
I'm gonna cry back we have one casualty
this we need to have like a like
beautiful red black and white photo
no but I think it should still say it's
just like do you bend Hey
Oh random yogs as well discover
surprises head hearts do you pick the
wrong to fight others I don't have TV I
become a baby was there they they bid 9
no doubt Tilda also also shows if
someone needs to get something done
right
doing the world video games
Polaris West and a Polaris East now
across the ocean was just gonna divide
play all the angry games together
oh my god join the game Scott Raymond
joy the kid but injuries we were about
to give you it in in memorandum you're
about to give you that no no that word
means I'm looking hard to get Valeria's
kicking ass over here she's running back
and forth between guns what she's not
hitting anything but you Oh
our enemies are hitting each other sir
she's not here anymore he's talking
about those crying cries so bad yeah
well I'm just gosh I'm sorry
I love it I got the boys gone I'll kill
them
we killed him good you can we kill the
guy you did really is zero zero for the
sport you hear all shake each other's
dogs later let's go
dawn cry
oh well Dodger found a mystical control
what Oh
exact looter what they understand ah
about the second hand
it always is toe is totally going down
the second he's going so we go down suck
every going don't all hit the rocks oh
don't hit the rocks you're all over it
cry you got it beautiful you're doing a
great job not shooting that's Dungy oh
no that just said [ __ ]
looking pretty I need you guys I need
you just get on the grid spread blimp
really weird Blin
someone gun I got it's my time to shoot
there's a beggar yeah okay took that
besides this balloon is totally down and
then it's a totally dead bird
okay wait he's just in range hang on hey
oh my time to show everyone time to miss
i alright so this is definitely it's
embarrassing okay it's scary man
definitely Stoke on something go oh I
can't shoot him yet
hang on Oh bang oh yeah crash himself
kitchen head good I am glad Oh
two Arab that's a number yeah okay I'm
all hearing this oh nevermind I came
we're gonna we gonna Ram the balls out
of this guy screw it
jeez man winces a captain ranchers but
don't use flamethrowers just Ram its
balls guys guys I can't give you more
thumbs up dog mmm man really
so we're switching ships yeah I guess so
yeah I think so Hannah and further
further mind games get rigged x2 I like
our ships just backing up it's good
still going it's still just reversing
good body butterfly goodbye nope it's
flied away now by with another victory
under their belt
who knows what awaits em with a good mix
of into the tide captain of the sky